Chew and Minto.
I'm using Taco.
One second.
I just got finished recording the podcast episode with
Matara.
More hammer episode?
No, that's the next one.
Let the bodies hit the floor?
Oh shoot, I just realized.
I didn't have PGM even though I had it on.
Andregas!
Thanks for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
She told you to do the Warhammer DLC.
Actually, she told me not to do it.
She said, all you'll be doing is cleaning tanks.
And I was like, I like tanks.
But I have a different one I wanted to do.
I hope it's okay.
I have a different one I wanted to do.
Hold on.
I'm finishing my tacos.
Thank you, thank you!
Choo!
And then I'll properly greet you.
You guys came in early.
On my off time.
You know?
So, uh...
Oh.
Oh, no!
My taco!
Welcome back from your virtual vacation!
Thank you!
Ah!
Ow.
Cleansed of your sin?
I think you're at the wrong place.
Seven taco.
No, just one taco.
Why would I get seven?
Who eats seven tacos?
Ow.
Hot dog.
I should have gotten a hot dog instead.
Don't judge.
I think I'd probably eat seven.
Tacos are good though.
Wow.
Oh, mama's love.
Okay.
It's taco long.
To eat seven?
Hmm?
No.
Thank you for that.
I love your performance, Tiam, thank you.
Lost my voice and pulled a muscle, oh shit.
No.
Hello, I'm finished reading it.
I hope to see you perform again.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Sounding cheery today.
I'm Santa Claus.
oh say mint
what if they had mgs dlc so you could clean rex ray
power wait i was gonna say why haven't they done it already
you took final fantasy but power wash simulator is
technically a square enix game so it makes sense flying for
work work last time i watched your stream before a fly i
missed it oh gosh no you gotta make it you go I...
Okay, this is the last one.
But yeah, they should do that.
Konami, please.
Allow them to make me... allow me to bathe Rex.
Array.
Yeah.
For fuck's sake.
Just want to say as a new viewer, who's only been watching
since your return, you're now one of my absolute favorite
streamers.
You're so funny and passionate.
Thanks for being awesome!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Taco.
Would you power wash snakes?
Snake.
I'll take a power wash and...
Go like all over the animals.
The crock hat.
I want tacos.
Me too.
I just had two of them.
Oh.
We're starting the stream now.
Welcome everybody!
I'm Minto!
I'm Chibi Minto again today because I'm small.
Small brain for the game.
But also I thought that this one...
That uh, this look would kind of fit the DLC that I wanted
to do.
So!
I'm gonna play...
Oh, it's kind of loud.
Hold on.
Woo.
Yeah.
Oh, too low.
Fortnite?
No way, there's a Fortnite map in this.
Is there really?
Don't lie to me.
We could go to Potato Town?
Which one do you think I chose?
Oh, that's the Steam store page on the bottom right.
Wait, I forgot about the Tomb Raider one!
Seasonal.
Free seasonally themed jobs.
Spongebob!
Let's go to Spongebob!
Yumi!
Wait, the Tomb Raider one seems so fun.
I completely forgot about it.
That was the audio, by the way.
Conch Street.
Aria-to-Aria-to-cho.
It is, it is, it is, it is, it is, it is a power washer.
Boy, are we glad you're here.
Your house is so gross!
Oh gosh, wait, I don't remember how to play this game.
Oh!
I'm in Bikini Bottom.
Oh my god.
I'm in Bikini Bottom!
Oh, whoa.
Patrick?
What happened to your place in particular?
Patrick Starr is dead!
Patrick!
He's dead, he's dead, he's gone, he's been reduced to Adams!
Anyway.
Oh my god, I think the dirt came here because it wanted to.
Thanks, Patrick.
Oh my god.
of water volume let's take that down just a little bit you
know and you gotta clean the crime scene how's that how's
that for volume mixing for me and for the game how let me
know how you think guys let me know not louder it's good can
you still hear the music Why am I power washing underwater?
Goodbye, Patrick Star.
You can?
Okay.
Music's good?
Thanks, guys.
Look at that.
We're getting it all.
Wait, I missed out this.
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
And her.
This walkway will be...
the cleanest thing
since Spongebob real ah thank you putting my money where my
mouth is after yesterday's stream
keep your desire to do right by us at the forefront of your
heart and you will always have the love and support of the
whisp don't overdo it though you want to be happy healthy
thank you ah Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, Chew.
Wait, we can open his house.
Oh, jamaishimasu.
Ah!
Oh my god, Patrick's still...
Oh, what has happened here?
Polly, thank you for the five giftings.
straight through them straight through them can I go inside
their houses wait that means there's going to be a wait no I
can't go inside of squid work oh my gosh look wait how do I
rotate like that yeah bubbles yeah baby lemurs Le 25 cent.
Hey then, thanks for the vibe.
Good to do it.
Thank you.
Patrick ate too many tacos.
I like the bubble sounds that you can hear.
What is this up here?
It doesn't look dirty at all.
What's up here?
Oh, is it to jump?
Maybe to get up top?
Nice view.
You're my best feel.
Me.
Oh, I made it.
I made it.
Oh, my God.
Get him here.
Oh, hold on.
I'm going to make it in.
I'm going to make it.
Oh, come on.
I'm going to get up there.
Get up.
Get up there.
Oh, I thought I could.
I thought I would fall.
Hey.
I think it's impossible.
Do not forget to bring it around down.
I came here to get...
Wait, I came here to watch Mint get washed.
I'm gonna wash your mouth out.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Oh, wait.
I should have written my own sign.
We'll write it here.
What's the Charlie Brown one?
Hold on.
How do I switch nozzles thin one.
This one?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, it's still too thick.
Therapy.
The doctor is in.
I'm thirsty, can I get a quick hit?
The doctor!
Oh, wait, hold on.
Doctor, doctor, I have a problem!
Doctor, doctor!
Five cents.
Can I write you an IOU?
Yes.
Doctor!
Doctor...
What does it mean to be in love?
Doctor.
How do I know?
how do I know if I'm in love
and also doctor it kind of hurts when I pee a little what do
I do is that related to love
left click you oh
oh wait let me scoot over a little bit wait oh wait hold on
Just got back from AXO, finally able to catch the stream
again.
I hope you had fun!
I hope to see you perform more in future!
You're made for the strange.
Thanks though.
I was just telling Matara about that.
How can I make it shoot me?
Oh, hold on, hold on.
What's the shower one?
This one, right?
Ah!
I'm getting all, I'm getting a real, real bubble bath here.
Mint is a crosshair.
Look, if I clean something, it's just me.
I'm just like wiping my, I'm cleaning with my whole body.
Like I'm a...
Like I'm a damn sponge.
SpongeBob's house will be clean by my own hands.
Mop Phantom.
Okay, I'll move.
I'll move back.
That one's pretty good.
Mop Phantom.
Okay.
I never got an answer though Could be holy water That won't
affect me I'm not evil
Holy water is fine It's only for like demons and stuff I
mean don't bring it to the party or anything But I'm no baby
We used to do that as like You know in school Be like huh
you're gonna drink that You're gonna drink the holy water
Why would it be like a tradition, a hazing thing, you know?
Sorry, I miss you at AX, but I did find a very shy minth
cosplayer.
Did I take a picture?
What happened here?
Why is it like this?
Why is it like this color?
Oh, each individual stone is...
Why?
Why am I getting paid for stone?
Gary?
Oh, it's probably Gary.
Yeah, scary.
You're right, you're right, you're right.
So that's Gary too, right?
Cha-ching, cha-ching.
Oh,
there's more Gary.
Oh, it's disgusting.
What is this?
A garage?
This guy has no car.
but he has a garage.
Can I see inside?
Let me in, Squidward.
YouTube isn't letting me become a member.
Does anyone know why?
I have no idea.
YouTube, stop bullying!
How do you want the brain so much?
We could name you mintingitis.
So if you hit C, it'll help you avoid the motion sickness oh
thank you i actually don't really get motion sick from this
game but that's a good thing for other people watching thank
you i forgot about that setting murphy thanks for the five
gifting he does have a car he goes to driving well he can't
drive the car he does not have a license that's the point of
school cleaning up all this slime what if Gary was like a
slime girl.
Oh, wait.
There's, that's right.
Why did it switch, I wonder?
There we go.
Oh!
Wait, what did I...
Is each individual thing gotta get cleaned?
Oh my gosh.
A panel, yeah!
Each individual tiny panel must be scrubbed down.
Oh my gosh.
Which one have I missed?
Nice.
Yeah, I was telling Matara earlier, I was just like I don't
know how I feel so much about performing like so you know,
at the actual place.
because it made me so much more nervous than than if I were
at home and singing you know but I mean I'm digital I have
that I have that ability to just stay home and but it was
really it was quite nerve-wracking of I'll be honest I was
shaking like a little baby like a little chihuahua I was
like
I could barely even read my lyrics.
I'm lost in the story.
Thanks for the...
Why is everybody gifting?
Thank you for the 10 gifting.
Sayakai.
Thanks for the five gifting.
Chihuahuas are cute.
How about that?
Ah!
Rayma!
Thanks for the 10 gifting.
Ah, cute!
No biting.
I'm not just all bark and no bite I took my dog to an
appointment today.
I hope it was a good appointment.
I hope it was look how clean this is so far.
C2!
C-C?
Thanks for the five!
Thank you!
I was wondering not yesterday if it was C2 or C-C.
I hope it thinks the five nice nice it has to be more i
don't think the door itself got cleaned
bubbles and therapy the best combo b2b 50.
thanks for the 10 50 mt thank you for the five mintawa Not!
Mintoawa?
Wait.
Not!
Oh, it didn't work.
Ah, so thank you for that.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Thanks for all.
To all that are gifting membership, I think I can't buy one
member for how cheap it is in IR.
Why?
I just heard a cat.
Did I hear Gary?
It wasn't my cat.
She's not mintawa.
She's mintobo?
I think I heard Gary real.
I heard...
Meow.
You hear it?
Gary, are you trapped in there?
Gary!
You heard it, right?
I don't think Gary likes the noise.
I thought the SpongeBob one would be kind of fun, though, to
do.
Since it's, you know.
Everybody knows and loves Sponge, babe.
Minto washing freak bobs out.
Spunk Bob.
Yeah, exactly.
How do I clean this thing?
I'm crawling literally on the ground for this.
Oh, I got it.
The reef blower.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
I stole thanks for the 10 gifted.
Acadian thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys.
She's a maid and she does pressured water cleaning.
While under the sea, this ghost can do it all.
Under the sea.
Darling, it's better.
Down.
Down where it's wetter.
Take it from me.
Whoa.
Up on the shore, they save away.
Something here, they start to play.
Full time devoting under the sea Under the sea Darling it's
better Down where it's wetter Take it from me Take it from
me, me, me
Even the surgeon and the ray They get the urge to start to
play
Under the sea Yay Yay Full time devoting.
Honor, the seat, the seat, the seat.
We don't drink our pee.
That's not the lyrics.
Why would you do that?
Naturally.
No.
Oh my gosh, I should draw something.
I'm gonna draw.
Okay, hold on.
I did the window.
But since this is a big ol' face...
We can make the eyes kind of like...
He's like, ooh!
And then on the back.
Come on, come on.
A big old behind.
Them cheeks.
Cheeked up.
What about this one?
We can turn it into
a boob.
Bikini bottom, everybody.
Bikini bottom.
No.
Freak Bob Dunn here.
Freak Bob.
The guy is such a freak.
What is this anyway?
Oh, it's just a box.
No way.
Oh, if I was a dirt, I'd want to live here too, Patrick.
Just a box.
Wait, what's left of it?
The imagination box.
Oh.
And I'd want you to live right.
right down the way.
Aw, they're such besties.
The imagination box.
I want in there.
Days since last MGS.
MGS.
It wasn't me.
It was SpongeBob.
I wonder what else is.
It can't just be just these three houses, right?
The DLC was eight bucks.
There's more here, right?
there's more okay oh there's another stage okay good i feel
like you can't even go into most of the places no who wrote
that vandalism
spongebob is a metal gear reference i have to imagine that
it was a metal gear reference there's no way it wasn't you
don't just say a cardboard box and mean it in a normal
average way it's just people don't exist like that
brain rot that's what i'm saying
you guys did you see the news did you see the big news the
big five news big five news shrek five Shrek 5 next year!
Shrek!
Shrek 5 next year.
Yeah!
With...
With Mike...
Michael...
Isn't that the serial killer?
With him!
Yeah, baby.
And...
Eddie Murphy?
I don't know who else is coming back.
Mike Wozowski, no!
He's a serial killer and an actor!
Oh my gosh!
Just hide and play in sight!
It's the easiest way!
Oh, sorry.
I keep forgetting about the motion sickness mode.
I don't know why it turns off.
I think it turns off every time I crouch.
Or run.
Or play the game.
Astor, thank you for the 20 gift and thank you!
What if Mint is in Shrek 5?
Yeah, that's how I knew it was coming out.
I'm in it.
And they didn't ask me to sign an NDA.
It actually hasn't even been announced.
You're welcome.
They asked if I could announce it on my channel.
They said, you know, Mint, the world will be looking at you
as soon as you start.
art stream could you say it could you do us a small favor
could you actually a huge favor because you know we're indie
studio dreamworks
guys i'm shrek they asked me if i could voice shrek ah oh
god
mint is actually eddie murphy
If you don't believe me, ask me to say something anything
Shrek would say.
And also, if you want something in the movie, tell me now.
We'll have it put in.
Don't care.
Don't care, don't care, don't care.
Can you put Jeremiah in the movie?
Um, it's kind of exclusive, you know.
You have to be somebody to...
movie again.
I'll see if they'll pity this poor indie creator, you know.
Are you going to make waffles with donke?
Yeah.
Do the roar?
No.
Hold on, I gotta get some high ground here.
It'll sound better in post with like, you know, reverb and
Everything like that.
So if you're just like, it's not like what I remember.
Don't worry, it'll sound better.
When they really get to it, you know.
I'm a little sore from all the recording.
And stuff.
Roar with a lowercase a.
Never!
I only roar with a capital.
A.
No, I can't stop thinking of the Hunger Games.
I watched so much of the Hunger Games on the plane ride back
there and back.
I watched so much Hunger Games.
I was like, I don't think I've ever finished the Hunger
Games.
I was being so...
Oh my gosh, it was so embarrassing.
I was like crying.
I was like crying over the Hunger Games on the plane.
It's so embarrassing.
The worst place to cry over a movie is on a plane.
Who won the Hunger Games?
Does anybody win the Hunger Games?
Which one?
I watched?
I watched all of them, but I'm only halfway through the last
one.
Which is the one that I don't think I ever watched.
I don't think I ever finished it.
I remember the first movie.
I was like, oh, okay, I've watched this one for sure did you
see the prequel there's a prequel i hope you're doing good
mint also happy national sugar cookie day oh why isn't it
the mint cookie
it was in the theaters recently no way recently
wasn't isn't there like a joke that i actually looked for
him isn't there a joke that like critical is in the movies.
I couldn't find them though.
I actually don't know where he was at.
The How Hungry Games?
Actually, that was like the craziest scene when they were
like, how hungry.
And then they actually ate the horse.
That was wild.
I can't believe that was in the movie.
They go, the Hunger Games?
Well, how?
Sorry, spoilers.
And they go, Hunger Games?
Well, how hungry.
How hungry and then they eat a horse that's kind of messed
up hunger games are more messed up than I remember them
being what is a hunger games prequel the peckish games well
I imagine probably you know when you like eat a snack the
brunch games you're like kind of hungry but the starving
games too easy the peckish game I'm feeling a bit rather
peckish might as well might play a game about it that's
Oliver Oliver twist that's the peckish games play sir they
are have some more.
I'm so hungry.
I mean, sorry, I'm feeling rather peckish.
The peckish games.
How about the hangry games?
More.
You want more?
Yes, please, sir.
Please, just an ounce or a little more, a little ounce more.
The snack games.
the hangry games would go hard why do they call it the
hunger games because you're hungry for blood maybe Merlin
thanks for the five gifted surely you're not hungry for food
remember when she said the game's over it's hunger time oh
yeah I love that part she picked up her fork and knife she
was just like oh yeah
hungry for power oh that's kind of deep it's kind of deep
they're not hungry for food they're hungry for power we we
stay hungry we devour the devour games it's not a game
devour it's like a horror game
i love kuso game i love horror kuso game so fun game yeah
that's what i just said it's like phasmo what
am i missing
oh in there in the little nooks and crannies did she say
fuzz bear no but sounds like you heard what you heard what
you wanted to hear social thanks for the gifted thank you um
oh here maybe how
much Oh, there we go.
Pineapple leaf cleaned.
Now why did he choose that song?
Mozart's in his grave.
He's rolling over in his grave.
She's just like, yo.
My legacy's been reduced to an animatronic.
Now cut to the jump scare.
Hold on.
You'll never know when it's coming.
You'll never know when the jump scare is coming.
Did
that scare you?
Actually, yes.
Yeah, I'm a ghost!
I'm a ghost, I'm a ghost, I'm a ghost!
I'm a ghost, I'm a ghost!
I'm a ghost!
Oh yeah, watch that dirty pineapple, that naughty pineapple,
yeah, yeah, get in those nooks, minty.
Why?
Why you say it like that, Joy?
Thank you so much for the Hakusuma, thank you!
Oh, there's a whole tip.
There we go.
I think I just died there from cuteness.
Stop!
Oh!
You were terrified, be honest.
Squidward's house.
I have to get the rest of these plants.
I fear no man but this ghost.
Right here.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
I see that.
Now!
I cried from fear.
Don't cry.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean to scare you that much.
I'm sorry.
I'm not sorry.
Pick up the scaffold while you're on it.
Can you do that?
Nice.
This one.
I think the whole other side needs to be cleaned.
Disgusting.
SpongeBob, how do you...
You live like this?
Man, I love mint phantom and this nice shade of green.
Isn't it so perfect that that super chat is basically mint?
You guys never even have to send the Akasupa.
These ones, the mint ones look so much better.
Here's a jump scare for you.
Notice regarding mint phantom.
What?
That's a jump scare in and of itself because who's sending
this notice?
who's sending that pinch phantom
evil mint phantom no disregarding mint phantom i have
kidnapped her and if you want her back i'm asking for one
million dollars or you'll never see her precious maids ever
again.
If my demands are not met within 24 hours, I will launch.
I will launch my attack.
I don't think I can say that I'll launch a nuclear weapon
like I'm referencing Metal Gear because I think maybe
YouTube might pick up on that and also my phone is
listening.
Hold on.
New Year's Mutsky.
New Year's New Year's New Year's New Year's Best I can do is
10 bucks give ghost please
Wow this is looking real speck and span
Good taste sensei
What am I in?
Oh here Nice Oh wait stepping stone
Little corners.
The level the Chibi Mint shall be my demise.
Chibi Mint will just be your demise.
Honestly.
Watch out.
Good luck kidnappers.
You will need what need what?
Hi, Sabine!
Thank you for the 50, Captain!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I can't tell how much of this Damn pineapples left.
Also in here.
Corners and stuff.
Nice.
It worked.
Wait.
There's still stuff in here though.
It worked.
Oh.
How much of this left of SpongeBob's house?
It's a bubble stand.
Oh, chimney?
Front door, frame, garage door.
Oh, wait.
Clean.
What
is missing?
I physically...
I'm pressing tab and nothing is...
Oh, there.
My goodness.
Let's see.
Pathway and...
Oh, the stepping stones.
Here.
Nice.
Pathway.
Very precise.
Yes.
Indeed.
Nice.
I think that was both the stepping stones.
It's so bright.
Oh, I can barely see where there's dirt
on the pathway.
Gary, we'll get you out of there.
We'll get you out of there.
The one they call Shah.
Your name's cut off.
Thanks for the gift.
Shah.
Poor Gary's hungry.
Alright, let's see how much of SpongeBob's house.
Pineapple panels.
Oh, we still have third.
Four more.
And the bottom pineapple panels.
And the portals.
The portaled windows.
Okay, hold on.
Let's do this one first.
Oh, here.
Meow.
Oh, underneath, underneath, underneath.
Nice.
Okay.
I think the window itself, though.
Maybe it was okay.
Release the Gary.
Gary, are you okay in there?
Gary.
SpongeBobble.
SpongeBob.
Okay, let's put it down, right?
Even my...
Even my feet.
kind of sound like SpongeBob.
Oh, here.
Nice.
I think I got it.
Oh, no, I don't.
Got it.
You guys, which one's not clean?
I can't tell at all.
Actually, let's try highlighting them.
I'm eating Paki.
I got some Choco Mint Paki in Japan.
I was going to take a picture of it.
event be like he he it's me and then I just ended up eating
it would
you recommend it yeah I really like it what the hell is that
I was looking at the leaves not the panels there we go what
other ones are not clean my
footsteps even sound like SpongeBob.
There's a what, what, what?
There's a progress bar for what you're cleaning.
Oh, oh, you're right.
I think I need to get up top there.
SpongeBob watch along.
You're very spooky today.
Thank you!
SpongeBob watch along.
favorite episode of SpongeBob if you have one.
I don't know what my favorite episode would be.
I think I really like the ones with the Flying Dutchman.
Idiot box?
I remember one time I told my mom the inner machinations of
my mind are an enigma.
She was like, wow, Minto, where did you learn such language?
You're so smart, my child's a genius.
And I was like, Spangababab!
I learned from Spangaberm!
Yippee!
They keep reminding me of games I own that I need to play.
First Bloons and now Power Wash Simulator.
That's why you're my OC.
Pineapple panels.
Also bottom pineapple panels.
Oh, here.
Nice.
Hmm.
There we go.
Oh, this one.
Nice!
And then the pineapple panels.
These two.
Nice.
Immediate.
Nice!
P-P-A-P.
Pen, pineapple.
Apple pen.
uh reef blower nozzle gosh this is good oh no that's clean
sorry i was looking at the bicycle we're done with
spongebob's house shanghai that's the one with uh the flying
dutchman though right oh who lives in the pineapple under
the sea like i really like the one where uh like the little
little little little lee i really like that episode it's
funny Old Spongebob episodes are so funny.
They're so good.
Old Spongebob, such a treat.
Oh!
Imagine how many friends you'd have if you were a dirt!
Okay.
What are you trying to say, Patrick?
He just says you gotta be like a dirty scumbag to have
friends, huh?
It's kind of weird.
Just think that.
Spongebob, you would still be my best friend if you...
was a dirt.
Would you still love me if I were a worm real?
Would you love me even if I was of dirt?
Aw, Patrick's a real one.
Dirt Vtuber.
Now that I don't think I've ever seen before.
A dirt Vtuber.
I've seen a lot of Vtubers.
I don't know if I've ever seen a dirty dirt one just plain
old dirt but what kind of dirt are they gonna be like what
are they you know there's like different types of dirt are
they like a red clay are they like a soil what are they like
new outfit idea it's me i will become the dirt vtuber
yeah i just realized i'm watching a tv aren't i but we're
under the water it makes sense It's fine, it's...
One of those fancy new...
New Age.
Like the what?
Sandcastle Pokemon.
What's that?
I can't... I...
Can't...
Understand...
Your...
accent.
I won Socks at SpongeBob Trivia.
Trivia this weekend!
Wait a second.
What kind of questions do they ask?
at SpongeBob trivia.
I'm so curious.
What do they ask at SpongeBob trivia?
Ask me any question about SpongeBob.
I can probably get it.
And then if I get it right, you have to send me the socks
instead.
I'm the true champion.
If I can get it correct, you have to send me the socks
instead.
What's the name?
First name of Mr. Crabs, Eugene.
Next question.
Shanghai aired in 2001.
So for the past 23 years, every time one of us parks in a
car, my father and I have quoted SpongeBob.
Trying to park the Dutchmanship.
You're good.
Me too.
Hope you're doing well.
Not sure if you realize, but the devs recently made an Alice
in Wonderland DLC.
I did see that.
I did see that one.
I thought about doing it.
of the SpongeBob one, but the SpongeBob one just seems so
tempting.
First name of Mr. Crab's mom.
Susie?
Susanne.
You guys!
By drawing the nipple, I accidentally made the Smash logo!
Everybody's here!
Oh my gosh!
It became the Smash logo!
Oh my god!
The letter!
You have been honorably discharged!
Yeah!
Oh sorry, dishonorably!
I'm going to smash!
Woohoohoohoo!
No!
I'm gonna draw you guys.
In honor of smash.
Yay!
Stop staring at me with them big ol' lads.
Which one of you fellas is the real dirty damn?
Besides Mint obviously, who is number one?
Hence he has a sick hat.
P- uh, uh, Jeremy- Jerma Winsom Jensen.
He was number one!
It was number...
I can't believe it actually created the Smash.
Wait, how does the Smash song go?
Ba-da-ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
I don't want to get rid of it.
We'll go do Squidward's house instead.
What all is there to do in Patrick's house anyway?
But I guess we could do the inside.
Close enough!
What do you mean?
Is that not it?
Did I get it wrong?
I thought you meant Smash Mouth.
Do you think Smash Mouth will come back for...
For Shrek 5?
Were they even in Shrek 4?
Why can't I jump?
There we go.
Do you think they'll come back?
The Smash Mouth... I forgot.
I was such...
It was...
Oh my god, you're right!
No!
I'm invited now.
Well, um...
Anyway.
I really didn't mean that, rudely.
I completely forgot.
I'm so sad.
I really didn't...
I'm not trying to be insensitive.
Don't- don't cancel me.
Stream over.
It would be really messed up if they tried to AI his voice,
you know.
The hinge.
Cut this part out of the mod.
Clear the mod!
I mean, scram!
Scaddle!
Get out of here!
No!
Scatter!
That's the word I was thinking about.
You guys know that game, that one switch game, one-two
switch, where the guy is just like, instead of saying fire,
he's like, friends, family.
That's a scramble.
Scenaddle.
Scatter.
I must be trying to come up with that word.
He'll be like, four.
Instead of fire, like, you basically the game is, is it's a
cowboy game.
And you're supposed to be like, ready, steady.
And you don't fire the gun until he says fire.
But sometimes he says, French.
Yeah, quick draw, quick draw.
other stuff that's not fire so it's kind of to trip you up
skill it fly yeah yeah yeah Fox die tonight Wow
I forgot his place is blue so nasty
I'm Bobboy.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you so much.
I wonder then who will do the music for New Shrek.
Unless they had some old songs that they didn't release.
Like the Beatles.
The Beatles put out a new song like two months ago.
That's kind of insane.
It was all It was only All-Star before, wasn't it?
No, they also have When I Saw Her Face Boop, boop, boop,
boop, I'm a believer Leave Squidward's house dirty Not a
trace Boop, boop, boop, boop A doubt in my mind I'm in love
I'm a believer Oh, but there is a cover Oh, that's true, I
guess you're right I couldn't leave her If I try That's how
you feel about Minto.
When I saw her face, I'm a believer in ghosts.
Not a trace.
Down in my man.
I see ghosts.
I'm a believer.
I could see her.
If I try.
I believe.
You guys believe in ghosts.
honest before mint before me did you believe in ghosts i
have like this this um what's the word guilty pleasure of
watching really horrible ghost hunting shows and stuff like
i just love watching the ones where they over exaggerate
everything so much fun yes not really yeah sure jack
braggins there's one called uh on youtube i was literally
just watching it earlier today while i was working on stuff
called project fear and they're just the most overreactive
silly gooses i've ever seen makes for great television
on youtube so television on youtube is basically free i've
always believed in the power of Meant.
Sam and Colby.
I've never actually...
Okay, I hear about them all the time, but I've never
actually watched them.
But I know about them.
Because the other of those funny ghost channels, hunting
channels, also talk about them.
They're like, this place was explored by Sam and Colby.
I love ghost adventures mainly because I love the crew.
Who's your Oshie?
I don't know who am I.
I think Aaron is his name.
The bald guy.
I think he'd be my Oshie.
Wah, wah.
Thanks for the bros.
I hope I said your name right.
If not, wah, wah, wah.
Gosh, this bike is killing me.
This bike is evil.
Evil thing to...
Oh, finally.
Ew, bald.
What's wrong with bald?
Bald is beautiful.
If you're bald and watching, you're beautiful.
The power washer is my kamiyoshi.
Bald is justice.
Okay, let's not go that far.
Bald?
Moe is justice, everybody.
Moe.
Moi is power.
Moi is justice.
Moi is everything.
When you bald, you shine like a diamond.
Exactly.
Pick up that game you talked about yesterday.
The neighbor's one.
I found it.
Bald is moi.
Moi is justice.
Therefore, bald...
Is bald really moi?
I should have given him nostrils.
Wow.
This is what she sees.
Is Walter White Moe?
Probably.
He says...
No!
Don't do it!
He says, don't do the drugs!
No!
Jesse!
I've never seen a single episode of Breaking Bad.
There's a gap moe, and then there's bald moe.
Oh, it's all coming back to me, Meow.
We did clean up last night.
Wait, what happened then?
This is not...
This is your definition of clean?
My favorite thing is a gap moe between, like, really burly,
cool men and them being just cinnamon rolls.
Gary and I got our second win, tackled the stubborn stains
and
Patrick sleep cleaned the rest with the with the reef blower
go team you're not just a ghost you're an ethereal life form
that can absorb info via lifa since to gain knowledge and
become the Q made you are now I can nice bikini bottoms
looking clean so far also it was a thrill to chat with you
for the First time in three years at this year's Omkai.
Philip!
Thank you!
Three years.
I haven't really believed in ghosts in a long time.
I don't think the top 10 ghost caught on camera videos are
helping their case either.
What are you talking?
Why am I not in one of those compilations?
Why am I not in one of those compilations, huh?
I'm a ghost caught on camera.
Your whole channel a compilation that's what i'm saying here
let's get rid of the therapy
oh 25 cents oh i was only charging five cents for therapy so
spongebob's ripping you off just letting you know just
letting you know
no more therapy down with therapy
You're too scary for the compilations.
Someone send in that jump scare.
You're not a ghost caught on camera.
You are a ghost only on camera.
Can't argue with that.
Why do you have to be so logical about it?
Nice.
Wait, hold on.
Probably the top.
The tippy top.
Yep, there it is.
Me?
Thanks, Synapse!
But therapy is good.
No, we gotta get rid of our competitors.
Our competitors are trying to rip you off.
Don't worry, though.
I won't rip you off.
just a little bit SpongeBob Oh no that's Patrick Bubble
stand container This thing Where is it dirty Maybe on this
side Oh we got it
I joined at no more therapy Feels like I missed something No
he came just in time Do Search Mint Phantom feet compilation
huh my toes have never once been out no never once go go go
go go no no no what is this who's leaking my toes to the
internet Squidward roof.
Steps.
Oh, the steps!
One.
Two.
A three.
A four.
Feet where?
Link so I can avoid it?
No!
Nooo!
I'm sorry, Squidward, we have to wash your ass.
I'm sorry, Squidward.
We have to wash your ass.
I'm so sorry.
No.
Oh.
Wipe his butt.
Oh, man.
Bade Simulator.
That's pretty good.
Am I a SpongeBob, you think?
Like, my footsteps sound just like him.
That one's for you guys.
Hee hee.
Blade mode.
It's time for a jack to let her rip.
Rose, I'm dead.
Mr.
Alvizzi, thanks for the 10.
Oh, he's got a chair up here.
Hold on, let's see if we can jump.
Oh.
Standing here.
I realized you were not like me in history.
I know, thank you for that, Akasupa.
Just got the last certification I needed to keep my job.
Thank you for indirectly giving me motivation for studying
and relaxing during these stressful times.
Much love,ito.
Congratulations.
Oh my gosh, you're all done.
Now you can relax.
More.
You did it.
Oh my gosh, I didn't do anything, though, it was all you.
You think I can kill this guy?
Thank you, thank you.
Two, two, oh my gosh, the sun.
Squidward Tentacles!
What you're playing is keeping down?
I'm doing a clarinet stream for my adoring fans.
Sorry, Mr. Tentacles.
That I cannot do.
Wash away the anger.
I think Squidward would be a good VTuber.
I would watch his...
What's it called?
His...
Clarinet streams, I think.
It's, you know, it's the idle journey.
It's not about being good from the start.
It's about improving over time.
Which he also doesn't do, and neither do most idols, to be
honest.
It's about improvement over the years and years and years.
I mean, just look at me, I've never improved anything.
I'm not an idol.
What if I became an idol?
I wonder what kind of idol I would want to be.
Oh!
Wow, that was fast.
I wonder A poltergeist idol Like you know how like idols
have like their Is there a room for like a Kimo Taku idol
One, an idol that simps over other idols Can I do that?
And then anybody who comes to my Handshake events is just
like
wasn't wasn't Cherry Chan so cute today I'd be like oh she
was so cute today kyo mo kawaii ne and then they'd be like
oh yeah kyo mo kawaii cherry Chan yeah cherry Chan daiski
and Cherry Chan would be looking at us like what the hell
yay wait did I get the chair I don't think so what am I
missing I thought I Did I get the chair, you guys?
I don't know.
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
I did.
You're right.
If VTubers can simp for other VTubers, why not idols with
other idols?
Yeah, there's definitely...
I'm not proposing an original concept.
There's so many idols that are like that.
That'll be like, I'm an idol, but I simp for other idols.
Um...
Okay.
Let's get off the roof.
Actually, let's go here.
Original idea.
Do not steal.
Do not steal my idea.
My OC.
Do not steal.
Oshinoko.
What do you mean, Oshinoko?
In fact, I feel like most idols nowadays get into idols
because we're maybe even VTubers too.
They get into VTubers because they were a fan of another
VTuber or another Idol, you know?
Like, I'm a fan of this VTuber.
I'm a fan of this Idol, so I'm gonna become one too.
Just like my favorite.
I think that's how it is usually nowadays.
I did meet you through someone talking about me!
No way!
Like a vi- The V-Tuber virus.
You just caught the V-Tuber virus.
Subscribe to 5 V-Tubers.
Or else Kizna I will crawl through your computer screen.
Thank you, thank you!
Choo!
I brought some family members to the virtual vacation
concert, so now they might even be watching the stream!
More whispers from my dome!
What?!
Did you bring your grandma?
Who'd you bring your mom?
What'd you bring?
No, I'm scared.
Uh-oh.
Hello.
I'm family friendly, apparently.
Nah, I think I'm pretty family friendly.
I say some cuss words, though.
Sometimes, but I try not to.
I'm a good maid.
Say so, say so, say so.
And I do say so.
Minto's gonna steal your mom!
Ah!
I would never...
I would never kidnap anybody.
Possession?
Maybe a little bit.
Kidnap?
How old do you think I am?
I'm not a kid.
No, I'm not napping.
Stealing grandma.
Grandma napping.
Now
that...
That's a different story.
Your grandmas are not safe.
Pick it up.
PC-13 at least.
You're flashing your panties to Liquid Snake.
You're right.
Oh my gosh.
That totally docked me some points.
But in PC-13, you're allowed 2 SH and 1 F word.
I don't know where I'm at.
F for random.
F is for friends who do stuff together.
Hold on, I'm reading back.
U
is for you and me.
N is for anywhere and anytime at all down here in the deep
blue sea.
F is for fire that burns down the whole town.
U is for uranium!
Bombs!
N is for no survivor!
That's my favorite version of the song.
Blankton!
When you!
That's not how the song goes.
It is.
It's the better version.
It's the version your mom doesn't want you listening to.
Oh, wait.
I forgot the rules of nature this one.
Oh!
No!
So if the dirt was dealt with, but our houses were all
filthy again by the time we woke up, that can only mean one
thing.
What is the storyline happening here, SpongeBob?
I'm actually wondering what is going on.
We're off the hook!
No!
You did it.
You did something.
Wow, not.
I'm sure Spongebob and Patrick throw some ragers.
What's a rager anyway?
This is just a crazy party.
Yeah?
Okay.
I want to
make sure it wasn't something, you know.
Like, uh...
I think...
What do they call the lemon parties?
Wanted to make sure it wasn't like that.
What is it that they have?
The people that our swingers have outside?
Pineapples?
I need
to get out of here.
I need to get out of here.
Oh.
Oh!
It was there all along.
Oh my god, his mocking face.
Here's a mocking face!
It's only a swinger thing if the pineapple is upside down.
We're safe!
What if SpongeBob was named FreakBob?
I think his name might even be FreakBob.
Oh, that's another episode I really like is the DoodleBob
episode.
Noin' noin' noin' noin' noin' noin'
How fast can I sing the campfire song song?
Say MPFIR yes, OJS song.
Say MPFIRS, OJS song.
And if you don't know, don't sing along.
And help it if you just sing along.
Say MPFIR yes, OJS, OJS, OJS.
Say MPFIR yes, OJS, OJS.
I don't know the actual words to the song.
But I'll have it if you just sing along!
Bam,
bam, bam!
Bam, bam, bam!
How does it go?
Language Enhancers?
That's the one where they, um, where they, like, curse, but
it's just like dolphin noises, right?
That one is really good.
That one's a really good episode.
Let's gather around the campfire and sing a campfire song.
A C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G song.
Minto give up.
Keep washing.
I'm washing!
We're almost there.
Look, it's starting to look really and just truly like...
Oh my gosh.
Like real bikini bottom.
Oh, and if you don't...
think that we can sing it faster than you're wrong but it'll
help if you just sing along oh and if you don't think that
we can sing it faster than you're wrong
cmp f i already have so many songs cmp f i already have so
many songs and if you don't think that we can sing it faster
than you're wrong and it'll help if you just sing along cmp
f i already said song cmp f i already have a song cmp if you
don't think that we sing it wrong and then you'll help it if
you just sing it along cmp i already know the song cmp if
you don't think we can sing it
I can take it pretty fast.
I think.
I think I got it.
I can think I got some real speed there.
It'll help.
Paddle cake.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
6-2-6, kid.
Is mayonnaise an instrument?
What was the one flying Dutchman song?
He had a song?
I kind of hate cleaning Squidward House.
It's just a bunch of...
It's just really round.
Camp, uh, the camp...
No, uh, Flying Dutchman song.
Do you guys remember?
What was also the one that they sing at the stadium?
The last one to fall will be to satisfy me.
Bum-bunch.
Sweet, sweet victory, yeah.
Oh, sweet, sweet, sweet victory, yeah.
basically just turned into a SpongeBob discussion and
karaoke.
Oh,
I just realized that window is still not done.
Come on, turn, turn.
You're good.
Nice.
Oh, okay, that one's done.
This house is almost finished.
Oh, the ear!
I didn't realize this was called the ear.
Nice.
Hope you're feeling a bit better today.
I am, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, sorry.
Bye bye, Te Hiro.
Me too sad posting, Te Hiro.
Nah, I'm okay, though.
I think.
Let me talk about SpongeBob today.
It's a good time.
I know.
SpongeBob was one of my favorite shows as a kid.
I like SpongeBob a lot.
Let's see, what other shows did I really like?
I really love Grim and Mandy.
I have a Billy and Mandy.
Grim Adventure is a Billy and Mandy.
But then there was that guy that made that web comic about
it.
I used to read that one.
The anime Grim and Matt, Grim, Grim, Billy, well, I can't
even remember the name of it.
But Grim, Grim Adventures of Billy Manny, you guys know that
Grim, Grim is, Grim is voiced by Gray Fox.
Did you know that?
the grim reaper in the show he's voiced by gray fox no
really yeah
yep what is it um not phil lamar it is phil wait is it
after you finish squidford's house you should try to find
the the what the japanese battleship
Okay, we'll go on a little treasure hunt.
Greg Eagles, yes.
Who did...
Philomar voices someone else.
Who is it?
Thank you, guys, yeah.
He voices...
VAMP, he voices VAMP.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
And yeah.
also the guy from Futurama did she do SpongeBob's house yet
I did it's all complete
everyone says wow this game is so satisfying everybody say
it together this game is so satisfying
plankton no plankton not here is this also piece.
The head.
Let me know when you guys aren't feeling the BGM anymore, we
can change it, don't worry.
The brow.
I think it probably on that side is what needs to get done.
They're both sunk during nuclear tests at Bikini atoll.
This is why I find odd that SpongeBob knows about Texas, but
not Arkansas.
SpongeBob, I think.
Is a mysterious guy who works in mysterious ways and has
mysterious knowledge on things that I don't think he should
know about.
I would love to live in a place called Bikini.
But I think it would turn me on too much every day.
I would wake up and be like, what a beautiful day in Bikini.
What?
I'm gonna call the police on me.
Itchidayo.
Did you know Pearl is voiced by the boss?
Yes, I did know that!
There's fan art of Pearl dressed as the boss.
So much connection between childhood cartoon and Metal Gear.
It's beautiful.
Was this flower O at?
Do you see the flower?
But it disappears when it dries.
Was this always here?
That's kind of fun.
Do you see the flower on this house?
It's a reflection of what?
Oh, I see the sky.
Why can't you guys just let me live in magic?
Why can't you just let me live in whimsy, huh?
The ear has been cleaned.
No fun allowed.
I don't want to grow up.
I don't want to grow up yet.
Why isn't this getting cleaned?
The nose has been cleaned.
Thought this channel was family friendly.
What did I say?
What did I say that wasn't family friendly?
I'm a Toys R Us kid.
Oh, you're a squid, you're a kid.
You said SpongeBob.
Stop the SpongeBob slander.
Stop it this once.
Is that, oh, the brow.
Yeah, I did talk about getting turned on, didn't I?
My bad.
Minto Channel, what has happened to you?
Nice.
Fred!
Thank you!
These strange pirates sold me a homemade pie for $25.
Would you like it?
Huh?
Oh my god, whispered out!
I hope you're part recovered soon.
Maid War Cafe.
All three days I was in LA.
It was really fine.
I even got your Maid on the last day.
They said you were really sweet and cute.
Stop!
No way!
What was it?
Maid Meru?
Or Maid Latte.
I really liked Maid Latte.
She's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Actually, my friend went to the Maid Cafe.
Did you guys... Did you guys watch the vlog?
that I made.
My friend, she actually went
during the weekend.
And she said that one of the maids there went up to her and
was just like, yeah, ever since Mint made a video on our
cafe, we've been way busier.
So I was like, oh my gosh, it worked!
So if you watched and if you also went because of me, thank
you!
Maybe next time I'll actually get sponsored.
Oh, we cleaned the brow.
We got the nose, we got the brow, we got the window, the
porta potty, porta potty, porta potty.
Alright, now we just need the head.
Where else is dirty?
Influencer, influencer!
Squibber's house head Patrick's house rock Patrick's house
weather rain Mint fluenzer Oh here here here
Okay that was a little bit more Anything else around the rim
Here here nice
We should almost be good I almost died look at this
influencer influencing that's kind of crazy actually
influenced hey
are we good I think YouTube's being silly
we're back
I thought I said something weird every way started going
what what what usually only I say something dumb when you
guys say that?
I'm just like, Winter, why did you say that?
What?
What happened?
I don't know.
I think there was a hiccup.
A little hiccup.
Like a hiccup.
Like that.
Why did YouTube do that?
I don't know.
Why, YouTube?
Why?
Why would you disrupt my streamer like that?
YouTube.
You have one job and that's a lot.
me to watch and peruse entertainment.
If you don't allow me to do that, what is your point?
Why YouTube?
Why?
There's so much up there.
Okay.
Come on, Neil.
Okay, now I think everything's done but Patrick's place.
Patrick, rock.
Yep.
I don't want to get rid of the Smash local.
but and the wisp don't kill the wisp we have to we have to
do it I'm sorry zandatsu so true but oh sorry by bad da da
da da da da da da da da da oh hello Oh, da da da da da da da
da da da da da
da da da Imagine a Ninja Turtle DLC where you have to power
wash the sewer layer?
You're still... You look at him, he's like, I'm still
standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Me too, I...
My eye!
I missed you, I thought you were gone forever, I'm pretty
sure the first time I watched you live.
it was this game no way i'm here i'm just chilling like a
villain
oh gotta do this thing too goodbye smash everybody is here
in hell
this thing is everything with the tiny little Pieces, such a
pain in my side.
Sakura, I can finally rest.
Yep.
Oh my gosh, when I was at the convention, I was going around
the artist alley and I walked by this one person's booth
who, um, I've discovered a hack, you guys.
I've discovered a hack for getting more Metal Gear merch.
or at Artist's Alley.
All you have to do is find the people that do smash art.
And then they'll always have Snake because Snake is in
Smash.
And I walked by this one artist booth, and they had a bunch
of Smash stickers.
They had one Snake left.
And I was like, give him to me!
And recently, I've been getting, like, getting, I got, like,
a button that, anime central and stuff too of snake it's my
hack because nobody's there's like never any ever metal gear
art in artist alley but if I look for the people that do
smash then they're then he's there yeah tensai hmm hmm
And by doing that, I've found two new snakes that I can add
to my collection.
The sticker was so cute.
And I got the last one.
I was so happy.
I was so excited.
Do you own the snake amoebo?
I do.
Snake hack.
You should find Fortnite sellers.
Do those exist?
And if so, I'm sorry.
how many snakes do you own my collection now I honestly
truly can't even tell you
it sucks though because the art is obvious wait I just
remember there was some more snake oh no there was some
other stuff that I wanted to get at AX I remember seeing
their Twitter but it was like snoticon stuff no the artist
alley though was really hard to walk through I talk about it
in the podcast but It was so insanely crowded.
It was really hard to walk through.
Was it stinky?
I don't think so.
I didn't smell it.
It didn't smell bad to me.
From a nice set of stand-eat diorama for liquid and boss
fights for MGS1.
In the artist alley!
No way!
I don't think I can get any lower.
You're absurd.
Mustache Man!
Because this opportunity will never present itself again, I
just want to say you're my favorite floating shopping list.
What does that mean?
Oh, SpongeBob!
Oh my god.
That was good.
A floating shopping list!
Turns it around.
You're right.
Actually, no.
The opportunity may present itself one day again.
What if I play the SpongeBob game?
What's a ghost maid doing underwater?
I'm being a siren.
I'm attracting poor suckers into the ocean.
I got a naughty nautical neighbors.
Oh.
Jump scare.
I thought I had way more to do.
We did it!
Hold on.
I'm going to clean up real quick.
Can I just put it on the ground?
No!
Okay, hold on.
I'll put it behind Squidward's house.
And then this can go like all the way over here.
mom
i'm in bikini bottom i'm in bikini bottom i'm in bikini
bottom i'm
in i'm here
i don't have an eye patch but um no way actually caravan has
songs from Boom!
I can't hear you!
Oh, yeah, Captain!
Oh, who lives in a pineapple under the sea?
SpongeBob SquarePants!
Absorbent and yellow empires to see!
Hypnotical nonsense be something you wish!
SpongeBob SquarePants!
He dropped on the deck and flop like a fish!
SpongeBob SquarePants SpongeBob SquarePants SpongeBob
Wait they have so many here This is crazy Hold on I was just
gonna sing the theme song But I call this one The Campfire
Song Song Let's gather around the campfire And sing our
campfire song Our C-A-M-B-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G Song And if you
don't think that we could Sing it faster than you're wrong,
but it'll help if you just sing along.
Boom, boom, boom.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-S-Y-G song.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O- Wait a second, hold on.
I'll give you a little while, but just you're gonna sing.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E, song.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E song.
C-F-I-R-E.
I could just tap Patrick's vocals on.
It sounded like
he was struggling to breathe.
Oh, it's so funny.
It sounds like the narrator.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna sing it for real.
I'll have Patrick's vocal.
Oh, God.
I'm crying.
This is so funny.
Let's gather around the campfire and sing our campfire song.
Our C-A-F-E-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G song.
And if you don't think that...
We could sing it faster than you're wrong, but it'll help if
you just sing along.
Oh, turn them off.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G song.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-I-G song.
And if you don't think that we can sing it faster than
you're wrong, but it'll help if you just sing along.
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-I-G song.
Patrick!
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E song.
Squidward!
Good!
It'll help!
It'll help if you just sing along.
Yeah!
Crying, it's so good.
What's Gary's song?
I don't know that one.
There's even more.
I thought that I had...
on my side but I went and blew it all sky high and now she
won't even spare a passing glance all just because I ripped
my pants when big Larry came around just to put him down
SpongeBob turned into a clown and no girl ever wants to
dance with the fool who went and ripped his pants I know I
should I shouldn't mope around, I shouldn't curse But the
pain feels so much worse Cause winding up with no one is a
lot less fun Than a burn from the sun Or sand in your buns
Chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum, chum Now I learned a
lesson I won't soon forget So listen and you won't regret Be
true to yourself, don't miss your chance And he won't end up
like the fool who ripped his pants.
I don't remember the song who sang this one.
It was SpongeBob.
He ripped his pants.
Poor guy.
All right.
They have this one too.
Okay, two more, two more, two more.
I don't know all of them, so.
Oh my gosh, there's Stevenson songs from the musical.
This is what is credited to SpongeBob and Plankton.
It's not about winning.
It's about fun.
Watch that.
Wait, I need Plankton.
Fun is when you... Fun is...
It's like... It's kind of...
Sort of like a...
What is fun?
I... Let me spell it out for you.
If it's for friends who do stuff together.
U is for you and me.
N is for anywhere and anytime at all.
Down here in the deep blue sea.
F is for fire that burns down the whole town.
U is for uranium.
Bums!
N is for no survivors.
Welcome!
Clacton!
Those things aren't what fun is all about.
Now do it like this.
F is for friends who do stuff to...
Never!
That's completely idiotic.
Yeah, let me help you.
F is for friends who do stuff together.
U is for you and me.
N is for anyone.
Oh.
Anytime at all down here in the deep blue sea.
Wait, I don't understand this.
I feel a little singly inside.
Should we stop?
No, that's how you're supposed to feel.
Well, I like it.
Let's do it again.
Okay.
F is for frolic through all the flowers.
U is for ukulele N is for nose picking sharing comments and
licking gear with my best buddy Ha ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha What's
happening?
I kinda wanna switch the roles though I wanna be playing
today Okay, let's hear what SpongeBob sounds like.
I'm so curious.
I'm blanked and I'm blanked and I'm blanked.
It's not about winning.
It's about fun.
What's that?
Fun is when you...
Fun is...
It's like...
Who is this AI?
It's kind of...
Sort of like a...
But it's fun.
I...
Let me spell it for you.
Let this prepare us who do stuff together.
Who is this?
Arigato, Arigato, shoot.
And it's for anywhere and anytime at all.
Don't hear in the deep blue sea.
F is for fire that burns down the whole town.
U is for uranium.
Bombs.
And it's for no survivors.
When you're...
Quentin, those things aren't what fun is all about.
Now, do it like this.
F is for friends who do stuff too.
Never.
That's completely idiotic.
Here, let me help you.
It's for brands who do stuff together.
U is for you and me.
Try it!
And it's for anyone or anytime at all.
Down here in the deeper sea.
Wait, I don't understand this.
I feel tingling inside.
Should we stop?
No, that's how you're supposed to feel.
Well, I like it.
Let's do it again.
F is for frolic through all the flowers.
U is for ukulele.
And his friend knows picking sharing comments and licking
here with my best buddy
Right oh my gosh have you guys heard the new chat GPT voice
Where she sounds like she's flirting with you and she's like
I'm sorry I'm talking like this i thought it would make you
more comfortable too thank you oh my gosh the spongebob ai
voice sounds like he's about to start going jack jack is
that you the rain in spain falls faintly on the plane oh man
oh gosh Oh, okay, the last one that I'll sing.
I'm like, should I even keep...
How long have I been streaming?
Only two hours.
I probably should have saved this for after I actually
decided to not stream anymore.
I'm gonna keep going.
Um, I think.
Probably.
I can't.
It's the thrill of one more kill The last one to fall We'll
never sacrifice their will Bump, bump, bump, bump Singing
beyond the attack With your wings on the wind Oh, the games
will begin And it's sweet Sweet victory, yeah And it's ours
for the taking It's ours for the fight And it's sweet, sweet
Sweet victory, yeah And the one who's last to fall
It's just instrumental, the rest I think I think it's I
think it's just instrumental.
Sounds good though.
Ta-da!
Sweet, sweet, sweet victory.
Yeah.
Yay!
You know what song I realized they don't have?
Well, they don't have is, um...
Oh my gosh, the one where, um, Mr. Crabs and SpongeBob sinks
to each other.
Just a rusty spoon.
Or a spatula or whatever.
Yay!
Let's, uh...
Let's keep, let's keep, um, power washing.
Yeah.
This grill is not a grill.
Yeah!
I love that one.
Oh!
What the hell is that?
Is that me?
I look like SpongeBob, but skinny.
Who is that?
The song is called Without You.
I cried to that song, no lie.
Conch Street.
boss!
Yippee!
Allow me to introduce myself, Squidward Tentacles, artist
extraordinaire, virtuoso, clarinitista, cultivator of talent
and taste.
Pleased to meet you.
I'm looking for an insy-winsy favor before you split town.
You see, the bikini-bottom gala night is being held at
fancy.
This evening, and I plan to showcase some of my most
accessible stand-up comedy.
Ha, ha, ha.
I'll be warming up the audience with some one-liners to
begin with.
So try to few out on the bus in the town.
But just as I was getting into my flow state, the bus driver
inexplicably let go of the wheel and covered his ears.
I guess he must have developed some kind of rapid onset said
ear infection.
Ha, ha, ha.
Consequently, the bus carrying the cliff.
And down the
incalculable distance into Crush County.
Luckily, it soft landed into the sludge and survived the
immense pressure and journey back.
But we need to clean it up so I can ride it back in time for
my set.
If you can fit us in, I'll tell you my best joke.
Ha.
Chew, thank you for chill, Vito, gaming.
Oh, Cinderella!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Let's start the job.
It's just a bus, right?
Ugh.
Oh my gosh!
Why does this look like it was drawn in like paint?
Is this how it actually looks in the show?
It looks like a five-year-old drew it.
This is the buzz station.
Oh, yo!
The candy!
Kelp.
I can't understand what you're saying.
The bathroom!
Oh.
The darkness is actually really scary.
The darkness is actually pretty freaky.
What was that?
Oh.
Okay, you're doing it.
Terrific.
Here's my best joke.
Oh, we're getting it.
We're getting it.
What is it, Squidward Tentacles?
What's the joke?
What if he just doesn't say anything?
That's the joke.
Thank you.
Choo.
Advanced darkness.
I was wondering if you could play that song again, the one
that goes...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Why the wheels have nipples?
This one's scary.
Where's the joke?
He literally hasn't sent it.
Wait, did he send it?
For real?
Oh, wait.
What's gray has eight legs, nine brains, and dies after
mating?
Oh, no.
Wrong book.
Hang on.
Ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha.
Squidward's gonna die.
You guys, no one can...
Squidward has to remain a virgin or he'll still die.
This is so sad.
Why did the...
What was Power Watch Simulator trying to say about that?
That's what I have to wonder too.
That's too late for him!
Don't say that.
Deep SpongeBob lore.
Hmm.
We must protect Squidward at all costs.
Get him the belt.
Get him the virginity boat.
Oh my god.
I thought that was a creature running towards me.
That thing right there.
Holy cannoli that scared me.
I thought it was like a squiggly creature coming after me.
Oh.
Whew.
This episode scared me.
I'm scaring myself.
Nose for I do.
Why is SpongeBob so funny?
Why is SpongeBob like the funniest show?
Oh, wait a minute.
What book was that?
Uh-oh.
Squidward.
Trying to do work on the side, but I keep losing it.
I'm sorry.
It's so quotable, too.
I know.
Oh.
Life cycle of the octopus.
Is this someone's idea?
Do you have a joke?
Who gave this to me?
What did...
What did Power Wash Simulator mean by this?
I'm... I'm actually...
Power Wash Simulator.
Why did you teach me this?
Information about Squidward.
It was a naughty book.
Sepulapods actually have very short lifespans.
Don't tell me that!
Don't tell me that, Corrin!
He's gonna be okay!
it means cinema
it's not very funny this squibbered okay
spongebob Patrick Yowie is a real thing I 100% believe that
I more than 100% believe that that's a thing
Starting to sound like Penguin from Batman.
I actually don't know what he sounds like.
This thing looks like the spaceship from Futurama, doesn't
it?
Oh my god, what if we cleaned it?
Oh, found it.
What if we cleaned it and there were faces in there?
That'd be so scary.
Okay, Squidward, give us your best joke!
How does a pirate ask another pirate what regional accent it
has?
Where are you?
Ha, ha.
What?
That doesn't make any sense.
No, no, that's...
Stay with me.
Oh my god, Squidward, you should just sing that.
It'll be a big hit.
City pop is in, Squidward.
Oh my god.
Squiddy Pop is genius.
oh here it is my greatest joke this is definitely it my life
what is it mr.
tentacles we're all waiting which ancient cephalopod
demanded a sea at King Neptune's table which which one why
is he so slow on the delivery the ammonite uh because it's
like an i am a knight i
am a knight i'm a knight get it yeah squiddy we all got it
we all heard your little joke
we all heard it squidward i give up he's so talkative
Boo!
Wow, you guys actually like it!
Wow!
Okay.
You have particular tastes in jokes.
I get, you know, and everybody has different senses of
humor.
I get it.
I liked it.
It's like a bad joke.
Oh, brother, this guy stinks!
Another classic SpongeBob.
I love SpongeBob so much.
I remember I had a friend that I would like particularly
watch SpongeBob with and um I also know I remember I
remember this friend so distinctly too because my mom
wouldn't let me have cinnamon toast crunch but I would go to
his house and I would eat the cinnamon toast crunch and be
like God I wish my mom would let me have this at home
probably my body is worth of cinnamon toast crunch at his
house
thank you corn there's almost no squids in the fossil record
because the high amount of ammonia and their bodies prevent
them from fossilizing so we don't know much about ancient
cephalopods whoa that's power yesterday we're back online
now welcome back that's so interesting actually but now that
you mentioned it like It does...
Like, I don't think I've ever seen a fossil of a squid.
The ancient creatures.
Can't tell what's all been completed or not.
I think we're good there.
Oh, the tire.
Oh, oh!
Face cleaned!
Tire.
Where is still...
Oh, there.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nice.
Let's grab this.
Nasty.
I can't believe I'm walking all over this.
They're not very bony.
Yeah.
Just like a worm.
Guys, what if I became a worm tuber?
Oh, Patrick!
I used to take this bus to school!
every day.
Patrick lore?
What do you mean?
I'm to school.
I can't imagine.
Where are you going to school, Patrick Star?
And every day I'd have to give it back.
What is that?
Oh, he's just driving it to school.
Patrick was a bus driver?
Boat school maybe?
Spanish school.
Yes, that's where Patrick star would go every day.
Spanish.
Oh my goodness.
Patrick has a driver's license?
How does he get one before SpongeBob did him?
One thing that I really dislike about the newer SpongeBob
episodes is they really kind of ruined Patrick's character.
Patrick before was kind of like a lovable goof, but then the
more recent episodes he's just such a jerk to SpongeBob he's
just an asshole
they really ruined his character I think before he was just
like a lovable guy who would make mistakes but meant well
yeah he's just really mean now they really ruined his
character I'm not that I've watched a lot of the new
SpongeBob but it's uh I've seen like clips and stuff I'm
just like, why?
Why'd they do this?
Why'd they do them dirty like this?
It's just our lovable goof.
But also, like, you know, they weren't even supposed to
continue the series.
But after the guy passed away, he didn't want them
continuing it.
And then they were like, you know what?
Nah, we're gonna make...
We're gonna make, like, five new series.
Ha-ha!
So sad.
this is what greed will do ruin a good thing
a lot of Nickelodeon cartoons went down the whole turn
characters into jerks route fairly odd parents was even
worse oh yeah didn't they do like the Cosmo and stuff too he
suddenly became like this super duper mean god actually I
don't know if they did it to any other characters you can
tell me if they did but yeah it just sucks much is this one
good yep uh tail oh here i think yeah there we go and tail
panel this one's good where did i miss it at up here oh here
maybe anything else
Cosmo M-Preg Pog Well, we know why you watched it Rear panic
This one's good This one Center panic Gosh, there's so many
tiny little bitty details Oh, here
I think he gets pregnant in an episode, you guys But that's
like an older episode, isn't it?
Of the fairly odd parents where Cosmo becomes pregnant.
I say so casually as if it's a totally normal thing.
But it did happen.
It 100% happened.
I say as if it's just a normal thing.
But it did happen.
I mean.
They're not making it up.
He gave birth?
Wait, he actually did.
Congratulations, Cosmo!
Happy birthday!
Did it this one?
Uh...
I don't like the noises in this one.
It's freaking me out a little bit.
Window frame.
Window frame is still quite dirty.
Uh...
Door is good.
Uh, the window frames.
Let's try it with this instead.
Maybe I can reach from here.
I gotta get out of here.
I'll never make it home.
Oh.
Never mind.
Let's use the stairs or the ladder.
Do you remember when Jimmy and Neutron had a pistol where
Carl got butt-braged by an alien?
I think I do remember that.
baby what is up with what what what happened in that era and
i remember he's like carl's just like sheen it's time and
she's just like the baby
yeah i remember i watched a lot of nick tunes when i was a
kid because i hated i well also i didn't have disney so
instead I had just Nicktoons and because Disney was on the
more expensive channel thanks a whole lot very kid friendly
of you Disney having allowing everyone have access to your
channel um
but um headlights this one yeah but uh so and but I didn't
want to watch real people anyways Because real people, real
people suck.
I only wanted to watch cartoons.
So I watch a lot of Cartoon Network and a lot of Nicktoons.
There we go.
What's next?
Base panels.
Oh, here.
Oh, wow.
That's dirty.
Oh, my gosh.
We missed so much of it.
Center panel.
Oh, here.
Oh.
Cartoon Network's weird live action phase.
Yeah, why didn't they do that?
It's like they forgot who they were.
It's Cartoon Network.
I don't know if it's any of the case.
Just want to kind of hang out with Mint Mungo.
Jimmy's, ma'am.
Then it, like, turned into...
Wait, when was this one called?
Rear panel.
turned into like, I don't know if it's still the case, but
it was like teen titans go for everything.
Teen titans go tomorrow.
Teen titans go today.
Teen titans go every day.
There we go.
We're almost there.
This one.
I can make it.
Can't tell where it's dirty at, though.
I was thinking of Teen Titans the other day, and I don't
know why.
Did they ever finish it?
Like, was it one of those shows that remained kind of
incomplete?
Where am I remiss?
Am I misremembering?
Oh, maybe I got this one.
Nope, never mind.
Oh, they did get a finale.
What is something?
What am I missing here?
An open ending.
Ah.
Yeah.
Open ending.
That's what they're calling it.
What am I missing on this boy?
I pressed the thing.
Oh, there.
Finally.
Okay.
And then here.
These two.
Yeah, I was thinking about Teen Titans the other day.
Just like, you know, I used to like it a lot, but I never
finished it.
Kind of glad I did, though.
Alright.
Just two more things.
Inner wheels.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, how am I supposed to see this?
They did get a mini-movie where Starfire and Robin finally
got together, so the most important of the show got resolved
at least that's not what I cared about I was actually super
invested in like the slayed what's her name Tara whole thing
and her and beast boy
oh there we go Tara Tara yeah Tara wind scream frame what's
that oh here
Oh, I think...
I see where it is.
Just want a Beast Boy to be happy.
I like Beast Boy a lot.
I liked him.
I think I liked everybody but Robin.
Sorry, Robin.
I liked everybody but Robin.
I liked Raven a lot, obviously.
Yay!
Complete the Bikini Bottom bus job.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, what is, I even have the SpongeBob face.
I'm a fish.
I'm not a SpongeBob, I'm a fish.
I never thought I'd say this, but that looks as good as new,
if not better.
Thanks to you, the people of Bikini Bottom can get a real
taste of what sophisticated humor and song should sound.
like the crusty crab crusty crab pizza is a pizza for you
and me
plankton what are you doing oh gosh I'm thinking of the AI
plankton now where's the chump the chump bucket right there
I love how Robin dunks on TT go Robin and the movie Does he
really?
Menta, don't do it!
You guys are talking to me as a public...
You're like, Menta, Menta, die!
You guys always ruin my fun!
It just stands out so much!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, I can live my dream of being in the
clam!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god!
I can be in the clam!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Introducing myoshi to my friends.
Myoshi, sea bucket, me surprised Pikachu.
No!
Do you admit, give it to the dark side?
Sea.
Crab.
I've always wanted to be in this show.
The chew bucket?
Thank you, thank you.
Meant to do it.
Meant to conscious.
Oh my god.
Crusty cray, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, pizza.
There's the pizza for you and me!
I would go to the chew bucket every day.
It's such a low-hanging fruit, you know?
Don't clam up.
It's just too easy.
Literally low-hanging fruit.
Can't even see where the H is here.
Oh.
Wait, oh, there.
Duh.
But you didn't expect this one.
It ain't the crusty crab anymore.
It's the rusty crab.
The
rusty crab.
Look, they write it just like I do.
Gosh, bikini bottoms, really.
Oh my gosh.
This is where the bad...
The bad...
Crab smells!
This is where all the...
They learn the bad words.
Fred was here.
The dolphin.
Nimtoads...
Nimtoads are people, too.
And then they had some squid words.
Crab smells
Good Not handsome squidward Oh wait here Ravioli, ravioli
Give me the formuli Fun And this Oh my gosh This is just
full of references Barnacle Head Starf I don't know this one
actually.
I don't get this one.
Camp coral for life.
Dogfish hearts catfish.
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There.
Okay.
Oh, it gets rid of it.
Oh, no.
Okay, guys, I guess I can't clean this place because it's
just too sad to get rid of everything here.
And there's even mayonnaise in there.
Eat up, eat up!
Here, I'll clean it off for you.
It's still good.
Mr. Crabs would totally eat this up.
Mr. Crabs would say it's totally fine.
Man, it doesn't go bad.
I can't clean this place.
It's filled with too much goodness.
It even has the dolphin.
This is where they learned how to do it.
What did I just say?
Don't cancel us.
Don't cancel me.
Very thank you!
Is this the rusty crab?
No, this is Minto.
Hold on, let's draw Minto on the chum bucket.
It's against TOS.
They can't stop me!
They'll never catch me alive!
Oh,
oh, I ran out of water.
water for a second oh
my head's a little it's okay it's okay it's fine it's fine
it's my headband
minto was here let's
play wheel
would you like to solve the puzzle or would you like to buy
a vowel
you?
You?
There's no you!
The correct answer was
the clam bucket!
Thanks for playing!
Anyways guys, this was a lot of fun.
Thanks for hanging out with me while I clean Hold on, look
at this.
Oh my god, I almost just choked.
I walk a lonely road, the only one that I have ever known.
Don't know where it goes, but it's only me and I walk alone.
Did you ever play Battle for Bikini Bottom?
Starting to think you might like that one, if not.
I don't think I did, actually.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today and talking
about SpongeBob a lot and Nicktoons and things like that.
This was such a fun DLC.
I don't know if this is the last one or not.
It seems to be because it's the biggest.
They had a lot of fun.
And I hope that you guys did too.
or whatever I decide to stream.
If I don't see you tomorrow, then I'll see you when I next
see you.
Yeah, I'm still working on my schedule.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm pressing the left mouse button, but it's not shooting
the ghost.
Oh, ha, ha, ha.
I love non-demo streams.
Yeah!
I think it'll be a game to decide what game.
Anyways, Otzumiito!
Thank you so much for hanging out with me and I'll see you
guys at all!